almost everyone I know that dated people
in the past before has at some point how
to partner boyfriend/girlfriend that
either cheated on him lied to them and
it hurt them and the reason why that
typically happens is because when we
first start dating
we're newer we're excited we're naive
that's when we get cheated on that's why
that's what somebody not this doesn't
mean people are never going to lie to us
again but we create this mechanism to
create filters if there's a video that I
want you to watch more than once this is
the video let me tell you why in the
world of business if you are not careful
and you go into this thing thinking it's
going to be all beautiful and exciting
someone's going to cheat on your lights
you take advantage you put you out of
business take your money do all that
stuff because there's a famous line in
quote I want you to I want you to think
about this year when a man with money
meets a man with experience the man with
the experience leaves with the money the
man with the money leaves with the
experience you do not want to be the man
with the money that leaves with the
experience with you lost all the money
you want the experience and the money so
no one can take advantage you and today
I'm going to cover with you a couple of
different things what I'm going to cover
with your four levels of trust and so
I'm going to cover with you seven
different lies that people tell and by
the way we all tell some sort of lies
but what type of lies it it will break
you down so when you go into business
you'll be able to say oh my gosh I know
exactly what's going on here and you'll
be able to categorize people write down
your business life in different levels
so let me start on this side here first
so trust who do you trust in business
who should you trust in business should
you trust everybody there's four levels
of trust number one from the lowest
level to the highest level what is the
lowest level you've never done business
with this person they don't have a track
record you don't know them they're a
stranger it's an absolute zero trust
number two it's a person that comes with
a resume maybe they've done well in the
past before maybe somebody recommended
them to you and it got a nice resume
track record so your trust level four
performance goes a little bit higher
because they got a track record number
three you trust this person
now you don't trust them at the highest
level but you trust this person because
you've done some business with them in
the past before and you know their level
of performance so maybe they're not
somebody they trust them what everything
but you know they're going to go out and
they're going to perform right it could
be a teammate that you know I can count
on this guy to come and train and
they're going to perform I don't know
for how long but I do know they're going
to perform at this level then there's
the highest level this I call a running
mate a running mate mate or running mate
generally here it's only one person let
me tell you this one person is it's a
person who calls and says hey Pat we got
an opportunity here I need you to wire
three hundred thousand dollars we're
going to put into this company no
problem okay call the banker that's a
three hundred thousand dollars in this
account done deal nothing but there's
only one person like this not fifteen
different people like this so if you got
a list of seven people here too many
very small maybe two three generally
it's one possibly three the longer you
run you got a solid lawyer where
everybody's involved and it's like a
limited partnership possibly yes but
generally there's one person that calls
and they say no problem by the way if
you're thinking right now you're
watching this video saying I don't have
somebody at that level right now that's
totally okay it took me a long time to
find somebody at that level you're going
to find somebody here overnight it's
like somebody who forces to find a wife
and they get a divorce so I somebody who
forces to find a husband and they get a
divorce
you can't force this this kind of needs
to happen because you need to get some
people that hurt you a little bit you
need to go through some black eye you
need to get something good some brawls
and some people with experience in yeah
that needs to happen too because that's
the only way your skin's going to really
get you know thicker and by the way the
more successful people you meet the
higher the success they reach they trust
less they don't trust more just so you
know that this whole books you read you
know motivation oh my gosh it's trust is
what it's all about
great this is here author's writing that
stuff whoever ran businesses and their
consultants I'm talking people who run
businesses who are actually in the game
that are getting killed hammered fights
brawls behind closed doors Oh
all of this stuff that happens there
Trust goes here it's a fewer people they
trust you need to get there at one point
as well so these are the four levels so
start exercising when you don't watching
this video going to watch it again put
people in these different categories
matter of fact Mario why don't we make a
PDF on this so people can go download I
just thought about alright we're going
to make a PDF and you're going to be
able to put people in these different
categories you'll download it I'll give
it you at the end remind me to say about
the PDF at the end so that's the trust
part here okay now let me give you this
other part here that we got okay
this other part seven types of lies we
all tell lies including you including me
we all tell lie but what type of lies do
we tell seven types of lies number one
white lies what's a white lie
babe how do I look tonight she looks
like she gained 25 baby look amazing
babe you're lying you're lying that's a
white lie hey Dad how was my baseball
swing buddy you're gonna be the next big
major league baseball player and that
swing was like this that enter Major
League Baseball you're a liar
I'm alive but it's a white lie we say
that at times to make you other people
that we care about feel good about
themselves number 2 plagiarism
plagiarism I've worked with people who
never ever ever wanted to give credit
for ideas I work with a lady in the past
before always took credit for all the
ideas plagiarism is somebody that got
the idea from somewhere else but never
wants to tell anybody else about it
you'll hear some people on social media
and on YouTube I mean I get annoyed when
they say things that's almost comical
when they say I don't read any books all
this stuff is naturally just came to me
like do you really think we are born
knowing ABCs like ABC I'm born ABCD efg
hijk LMNOP qrs tuv arrow x y z now i
know my abc ethan were born knowing 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 somebody passed that
information to you but there are
something that I don't want to give
credit because it's me because it's
about them I have a problem with that
when you get credit from someone I got
this from this book I got this one this
person says this plagiarism right next
exaggeration what is exaggeration
exaggeration sales people do it sales
people do it all the time you know hey
we're going to
don't do this you're exaggerating right
how are we going to projections we're
going to go 79% you're exaggerating now
why is that there's a part of it that's
because sales people are very optimistic
that they're going to kill it and I've
been in sales all my life and you always
think you're going to make more money
this year than you do and it typically
ends up taking a lot longer to build a
business so exaggeration is another sort
of a form of lie by the way for it's
compulsive life man you've got to be
careful compulsive liars once I figure
out someone's a compulsive liar let me
tell you almost everything they say I
can debate it because it's just pure
lies coming through you got to
categorize compulsive liars and be very
very careful with compulsive lives it's
not hard to catch them by the way
because they're so good at always lying
they think they're so good they
eventually get caught once they get
caught that credit score goes from there
to here what are you going to do from
there okay and if they don't show any
effort and wanting to improve that
that's just kind of how they are and by
the way you're not judging you're not
doing anything you just need to know
that's exactly who this person is on
what they're doing number five Blake you
know what a blatant liar is blatant liar
is somebody that looks at you in your
face they know that you know they're
lying and they still like your face
that's a blatant liar okay they know
that you know that they're lying and you
know they're lying and they still say to
your face number six not keeping your
word hey I'm gonna go up there go juice
they don't do it yeah I'm going to come
through with about the deadline they
don't do it yeah I'm gonna come to
Amazon they don't do it you know I just
came back from Miami I love this guy I
just went there for funeral very
emotional funeral I left Salt Lake City
I went I went over there and we were
there we were talking with a few of our
friends and a couple the names came up
conversations came up and I said look I
had a lot of friends in my life that I
knew I can't count on them to come
through for nothing I just can't count
on them to come through for nothing but
I can still be friends with them but I
just know they're not going to come to
look for anything because they never
keep their word that's a lie now last
but not least is at this sequel you know
what a deceiver is a deceiver is a
person that
let's just say all the information that
we have here there's 80 pieces of
information but they only tell you two
or three that benefit them and they try
to deceive you
whatever that benefits them only by the
way I do business with deceivers but I
know they're deceivers and I also know
what role they're going to play but
they're deceivers I know exactly where
they're at and I still figure out a way
to make money with them as long as I
know they're deceivers and you need to
know that as well so the point isn't
here let me explain to what this video
is all about this video isn't about you
going out there and battle people are
bad people man
they suck everybody is out there to get
me oh no no no no no no when you get
into a boxing match you can't say the
opponent is a bad person all he wants to
do is knock my ass up no no you get
better at defense is what you got to do
you can't go out and change other people
you can't go out and show oh my gosh
this guy knocked me out in front of my
wife and my kids he wanted to knock me
out it's his job to do that
your job is key boom boom boom work on
your court get your cell phone get your
arms up here on your toes energize
workout conditioning your sub so you can
last long you can go to the 12-round
you're not just a six-round guy and all
of them hope you catch it did you see
what he was Chyna he was trying to
deceive you one of the guys up fights oh
my gosh I feel like I'm getting knocked
out he's deceiving you and you come at
home he hits you that's the deceiver you
just need to know all these people and
I'm telling you right now this is not a
motivational video those are the ones
that go viral this one is the video that
purely is going to make you and save you
millions millions of dollars of money of
legal fees of all these other things
that you're going to face but more
importantly let me see that pillow you
know what it's going to do I'm not
asking you to subscribe right now you
know what this is
you know what this is
soft pillow you know it's a great
another soft pillow you sleep better at
night you know what causes you not to
sleep good at night when you don't know
how to handle people like this and when
you don't know how to do this and you
face somebody boom they get you you get
hot so for me I have to decide the
people I'm doing business with they will
generally tell you I'm not here I'm here
no problem I'm here it's ok I do a lot
of this I know I do this cool we know on
this I can deal with your light lines I
to white lies every day to my kids
that's how you start believe me to do
something bigger I know this is but I
know your roles and great and we work on
that and we go from there and you will
be able to do the same thing as well and
one day not today some of you guys are
going to comment on the bottom and you
know what you're going to comment on the
bottom you're going to talk about your
experiences I had somebody my business
that was this I have somebody that was
in my business that was that I had
somebody in my business that was here
but what I don't want to see you do is
the following if you blame that's the
reason why you didn't make it in
business what you're saying to the world
is I don't control my destiny somebody
else does and you are not right you're
wrong you control it you control it it's
in your hands
all about pivoting all about adjustments
all about audibles all about small
little moves that you need to be making
and all of a sudden you become somebody
in a boardroom where you send a
boardroom like a playbook you go tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick boom
boom boom boom boom I know everybody in
this room you guys ready let's negotiate
Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom
cool awesome thanks guys let's go rock
and roll and you know you're protected
so anyways I hope you're not a somebody
that's getting scared off this video
saying oh my gosh I don't want to go
into the world of business because the
world of business is a pretty strong
the business you're going to get into a
lot of brawls and fight and this is why
entrepreneurship may not be for
everybody but if you got the courage to
get into it and you face some other
stuff and you get very good at it you
end up becoming a hero to a lot of
people who say oh my gosh I cannot
believe how amazing he is or she is in
business because you know how to handle
some of these situations that some
people don't so who should you trust in
business now you have a formula for
Demario we promise we're going to get a
PDF so if you go to I'm gonna put the
link we're going to put the link on the
bottom they'll find it if you don't find
it you'll go to Patrick babe David let's
students we have known this for a while
go to Patrick Lee David come to the
stores it's the works this is like
ridiculous can we like upgrade the sound
a little bit let's try it like this new
sounds here okay go to Patrick wait
David calm they should type in what who
to trust in business it'll come up if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
yet for entrepreneurs we want to get 2
million subs by the end of the year
click on the subscribe button right here
and join the notification squad by
clicking the alert you'll be wonderful
every single time comes out this is why
I get the notification squad comments on
the bottom and for all of you that are
value tenures you've got questions
thoughts anything stories you got about
this video here comment on the bottom
take everybody go by
[Music]